This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Today we're going to start back in the 1970s at a Catholic school in South Los Angeles. It is picture day and all of the kids are filing into the school auditorium in their uniforms. They wearing powder blue sweaters, white shirts, and dark coloroys. And they would be a photographer, they're usually a white guy. This is Ibario Dexperelo, who attended the school. And they would just march all the students in, and you would sit on this stool,
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。今天我们要从 20世纪 70年代洛杉矶南部的一所天主教学校说起。那天是拍照日，所有孩子都穿着制服排着队走进学校礼堂。他们穿着浅蓝色毛衣、白衬衫和深色灯芯绒裤子。通常会有一位摄影师，大多数情况下是个白人。伊巴里奥·德克斯佩雷洛曾在这所学校就读，他回忆说。他们会把所有学生带进去，然后你坐在凳子上，
and you have your look at the camera, and you would make a couple of pops to the flies, and then you were done. After a few weeks, the students would get their photos back in a big envelope towards the end of the school day. And everybody wanted to share what everyone else's photographs looked like. They wanted to see what do your pictures look like. And the kids who had darker skin tone were always just, there was always a kind of negative reaction to that. Because the kids with lighter skin
看着镜头，摄影师会打几下闪光灯，然后就拍完了。几周后，学生们会在放学前收到一个装着照片的大信封。每个人都想看看别人的照片是什么样的。他们想看看你的照片拍得怎么样。而那些肤色较深的孩子总会引起一种负面反应。因为肤色较浅的孩子
looked basically like themselves, but the kids with darker skin looked way darker than they did in real life. A lot of the detail in their faces was just lost in the shadows. And the kids, kids could be cruel. You know, they all, you look so dark, it looks so black. That was the first sense that there was something different about how people look in photographs. That experience stuck with him, but Porello didn't realize why this was happening until later in his life. When Porello got a little older, he learned how to use a camera. Reporter Kai McNamey.
拍出来的样子基本上和真人差不多，但肤色较深的孩子拍出来的照片比现实中黑得多。他们脸部的大部分细节都在阴影中丢失了。而且孩子们有时很残酷。你知道，他们都会说，你看上去真黑，黑得像块炭。那是他们第一次意识到，人们在照片里的样子与现实有所不同。这种经历深深印在了佩雷洛的脑海里，但直到多年后，他才明白这背后的原因。当佩雷洛长大一些后，他学会了如何使用相机。记者凯·麦克纳米报道。
And the process of creating an image out of nothing just seemed like magic to him. But even as Perillo grew to love photography, he kept running up against the problem he first noticed back on school picture day. Capturing images of people with darker skin tones posed certain technical challenges. Sometimes he felt as if he had to work against the limitations actually built into the camera and the film. And that's because even if we think of the camera as a neutral technology, it is not. In the vast spectrum of human colors, photographic tools and practices tend to prioritize the lighter
从无到有创造出一张影像的过程，对他来说就像变魔术一样。但随着佩雷洛越来越热爱摄影，他却不断遇到他在学校拍照日那天首次注意到的问题。拍摄肤色较深的人的影像带来了一些技术挑战。有时他觉得自己在与相机和胶片本身内置的局限性作斗争。这是因为，尽管我们认为相机是一种中立的技术，但事实并非如此。在人类肤色的广阔光谱中，摄影工具和实践往往更偏向于较浅的那一端。
end of that range. And that bias has been there since the very beginning. It is not an overstatement to say that the history of photography can be divided into two eras, BK and AK, before Kodak and after Kodak. In 1888, George Eastman introduced a camera that revolutionized photography, making it accessible to thousands of amateurs. Kodak simplified the camera
这种偏见从一开始就存在。毫不夸张地说，摄影史可以分为两个时代：BK 和 AK，即柯达之前（Before Kodak）和柯达之后（After Kodak）。1888年，乔治·伊斯曼推出了一款彻底革新摄影的相机，使成千上万的业余爱好者能够接触到摄影。柯达简化了相机，
and offered to process film for the consumer. One of the company's early advertising slogans was you press the button, we do the rest. Kodak quickly grew into the biggest player in the industry. The company became almost synonymous with photography itself, like the Kleenex of cameras. Kodak wanted to be the company that recorded family histories. This is Lorna Roth, a recently retired communications professor
并为消费者提供冲洗胶卷的服务。该公司早期的广告标语之一是“你按快门，其余交给我们”。柯达迅速发展成为该行业最大的巨头。这家公司几乎成了摄影本身的代名词，就像相机的克烈尼斯（面巾纸）一样。柯达希望成为记录家族历史的公司。这是洛娜·罗斯，
at Concordia University. By the mid-20th century, most people were shooting their family pictures with Kodak film. most people were shooting their family pictures with Kodak film. ["The World of the World"] ["One Little Girl, One Precious Childhood, save for years to come, in pictures. You can do it too. All it takes is a camera, Kodak film, and thoughtfulness."
康考迪亚大学最近退休的传播学教授。到了20世纪中叶，大多数人都用柯达胶卷拍摄他们的家庭照片。大多数人都用柯达胶卷拍摄他们的家庭照片。“世界的世界” “一个小女孩，一段珍贵的童年，在照片中保存多年。你也可以做到。这一切只需要一台相机、柯达胶卷和用心。”
To meet the booming demand for photo processing and printing services, one of our photo labs popped up all over the country. And Kodak supplied a lot of these labs with printers. Here's where you can start to see the enormous power the company had to set the standards for film and film development. Each Kodak printer needed to be calibrated and standardized before photos were printed on it. And so the printers came with something called a Shirley Card, which was a color reference card created by Kodak in the 1950s. The original one had some color swatches and a picture of a white woman named Shirley Page, who worked as a Kodak employee at the time. She was used as a basis for measuring and calibrating the skin tones in the photographing printers.
为了满足对照片冲洗和打印服务激增的需求，我们的许多冲洗实验室如雨后春笋般在全国各地涌现。柯达为其中许多实验室提供了打印机。在这里，你可以开始看到该公司在制定胶卷和胶卷冲洗标准方面拥有巨大的权力。每台柯达打印机在打印照片前都需要进行校准和标准化。因此，打印机配备了一种叫做“雪莉卡”（Shirley Card）的东西，这是柯达在 20世纪 50年代创建的色彩参考卡。最初的版本包含一些色块和一位名叫雪莉·佩奇的白人女性的照片，她当时是柯达的一名员工。她被用作测量和校准摄影打印机肤色的基准。
The way it worked was that Kodak would ship printed Shirley cards to photo labs across the country, along with the film negatives needed to print the same image. Lab technicians processed the film, printed it, and ended up with multiple test prints. This allowed them to compare the Shirley cards printed at Kodak with the Shirley cards printed in the lab. If something didn't look right with the colors, they'd adjust. Once the printers were set, they'd start feeding film into the machines, cranking out hundreds of rolls a day.
它的工作原理是，柯达会将印有雪莉的卡片以及打印同一影像所需的胶卷底片一起寄给全国各地的照相馆。实验室技术人员冲洗胶卷、打印，最终得到多张测试打印件。这使他们能够将柯达打印的雪莉卡与实验室打印的雪莉卡进行比较。如果色彩看起来不对劲，他们就会进行调整。一旦打印机设置好，他们就会开始将胶卷送入机器，每天印制几百卷。
As time went on, Kodak began including other women on the cards, not just Shirley Page. And they, I think, just decided to name all of the women who were going to be in that position. They were all going to be in the end, surely because it was easier that way. They were all going to be in the end surely because it was easier that way. But even as Kodak expanded the number of women
随着时间的推移，柯达开始在卡片上加入其他女性，而不仅仅是雪莉·佩奇。我想他们只是决定将所有将要担任这个职位的女性都命名为雪莉，因为这样更简单。他们最后都叫雪莉，因为这样更简单。但即便柯达增加了卡片上女性的数量，
represented on the cards, all the surely's continued to be white. Whiteness was invisible, whiteness was the norm. On some of these images of the surely cards, it was written the normal. Because all the surely's were white, it meant that the printers were set for white skin. And Shirley was basically used to calibrate every printer, every time, regardless of the color of the people in the actual photographs being printed.
所有的雪莉仍然都是白人。白人是隐形的，白人是常态。在其中一些雪莉卡的影像上，甚至写着“正常”（the normal）。因为所有的雪莉都是白人，这意味着打印机的设置是针对白人肤色的。雪莉基本上被用来校准每一台打印机，每一次都如此，而不管实际打印照片中的人们肤色如何。
To get accurate prints or a person with darker skin or even someone in a different lighting environment, you might have to adjust the printer settings. But that just wasn't happening at most one hour photo labs. They weren't about customized service. They were about being fast, standardized, and relatively cheap. Because it was about getting that stuff out because you had a line of people out the door,
为了获得准确的冲洗效果——无论是肤色较深的人，还是处于不同光线环境中的人——你可能需要调整打印机设置。但在大多数一小时快照店里，这种情况根本不会发生。他们追求的不是定制服务。他们追求的是快捷、标准化和相对便宜。因为一切都是为了快点出货，门外排着一队人，
dropping film off and waiting to pick it up. This is Everard Williams Jr. He teaches photography at the Art Center College of Design in Pasadena. Back in the 80s, he worked at a 1-hour photo lab. And he says that lots of different kinds of people used to get their photos printed there. The demographic was everybody. It wasn't like it was say, oh, it's old white men that were wealthy that had enough money to buy a fancy camera and shoot some film. You would
送来胶卷并等着取照片。这是小埃瓦拉德·威廉姆斯。他在帕萨迪纳艺术中心设计学院教授摄影。早在 80年代，他曾在一家一小时快照店工作过。他说，各种各样的人过去常在那里冲洗照片。客群是所有人。不像人们说的那样，哦，只有有钱买得起昂贵相机并拍摄胶卷的年长富裕白人才去。你会看到
get everybody because making pictures is important to everybody because it helps kind of preserve the family legacy memory of something that's important. But the way that photography prioritizes white skin goes beyond the role of Shirley Cards. If that were the only problem, it would be relatively easy to fix. Instead, issues can start much earlier in the process,
所有人，因为对每个人来说，拍照都很重要，它有助于保存家族传承或重要事物的记忆。但摄影优先考虑白人肤色的方式不仅限于雪莉卡的作用。如果那是唯一的问题，那就相对容易解决。相反，问题在流程的更早阶段就已经开始了，
including the lighting and camera settings used to capture the picture. Take, for example, Ibario Nexperrello's Disaster School Picture Day. That day, the photographer probably showed up and set up the lighting the same way he'd done hundreds of times before. Yeah, they probably just got in front of it, took a light meter reading, where the kid was supposed to be, gave him a neutral value for that exposure and that's what they went for for the rest of the day. That was it. The photographer made a call because that's what photographers have to do.
包括用于捕捉影像的灯光和相机设置。以伊巴里奥·内克斯佩雷洛灾难般的学校拍照日为例。那天，摄影师可能出现并设置了灯光，就像他以前做过数百次那样。是的，他们可能只是走到灯光前，对孩子原本应该在的位置进行测光读数，给该曝光提供一个中性值，然后他们一整天都采用这个设置。就是这样。摄影师做出了决定，因为摄影师必须这样做。
Taking pictures is all about trade-offs and making decisions about which colors you want to prioritize. In this case, the photographer prioritized the lighter skin kids during the setup, which meant that the kids with darker skin tones just didn't look as good. There was no nuance to, you know, making it look good or adjusting it for the nuances of skin tone. It was like, you got an exposure,
拍照全关乎取舍，以及决定你想优先考虑哪些颜色。在这种情况下，摄影师在布光时优先考虑了肤色较浅的孩子，这意味着肤色较深的孩子拍出来效果就是不够好。这里没有任何细微差别，比如把它拍好，或者为了肤色的大地色调微调。这就像是，你测好了曝光，
you take the picture, move on to the next kid. But even if the photographer had finessed the lighting in camera settings with a range of skin tones in mind, there would still be another problem. The film itself was optimized for white skin. If you imagine light as a gradient from black to white, there's only a small chunk of that gradient that's visible to a camera. Dynamic range describes the width of that chunk that a camera sees. The wider the range, the more tones the film is able
按下快门，然后拍下一个孩子。但即便摄影师在考虑到各种肤色的情况下微调了灯光和相机设置，仍然会有另一个问题。胶卷本身就是为白人肤色优化的。如果你把光线想象成从黑到白的渐变，相机只能看到这个渐变中的一小块。动态范围描述了相机能看到的这一块的宽度。范围越宽，胶卷能够捕捉到的色调就越多，
to capture, the more accurate the image. But historically, consumer film, like the kind made by Kodak, was pretty limited. If you have experience making pictures of people with darker skin tones, you know how to compensate for all these limitations in the technology. You know you need to change the shutter speed, open up the lens or use a flash. Film may have challenges recording shadow detail, just the physics and the chemistry and how film functions, but there are ways to compensate
影像就越准确。但从历史上看，消费级胶卷——比如柯达制造的那种——非常有限。如果你有拍摄肤色较深的人的经验，你就会知道如何弥补这些技术上的所有局限性。你知道你需要改变快门速度、开大光圈或使用闪光灯。胶卷在记录阴影细节方面可能会有挑战，这是物理、化学以及胶卷运作方式决定的，但你可以通过布光方式或曝光方式来弥补这一点。
for that in terms of how you might light something or how you might expose something. So as a black photographer, photographing largely black people, we're very conscious of that. Photographers like Gordon Parks made amazing and indelible images of black life using the tools available to them. But that's because they cared enough to figure out how to do it well. Many photographers just haven't, resulting in the kinds of images that Porello remembers from picture day. And it might seem like a small thing, school picture day. But multiply that experience hundreds of thousands of times, not just with professional portraits,
因此，作为一名主要拍摄黑人的黑人摄影师，我们对此有着清醒的认识。像戈登·帕克斯这样的摄影师利用他们手头的工具，创作了令人惊叹且永垂不朽的黑人生活影像。但那是因为他们足够用心去弄清楚如何做好它。许多摄影师却没有这样做，从而导致了佩雷洛在拍照日记忆中的那种影像。学校拍照日可能看起来是一件小事。但把这种经历乘以几十万次，不仅是专业肖像，
but also with home photography, all the birthdays and family gatherings and events where pictures are taken. And think about the impact of not being able to see yourself quite literally in those pictures. I can't help but think that not seeing your face and what you look like and what your family looks like and what your friends look like, being lifted up as an example of beauty, really distorted these kids' impressions of what is attractive and what's not, what's good and what's bad. The poor way they are rendered when they are seen, that cumulatively has a really negative effect. Over time, the problems with Kodak's film became clear.
还有家庭摄影、所有的生日、家庭聚会以及拍照的各种活动。想想看，无法在那些照片中字面意义上地看到自己，会产生什么影响。我不禁认为，看不到自己的脸、自己的长相、家人和朋友的长相被提升为美的典范，确实扭曲了这些孩子对什么是美、什么是丑、什么是好、什么是坏的印象。当他们被看到时，那种糟糕的呈现方式，累积起来会产生真正负面的影响。随着时间的推移，柯达胶卷的问题变得显而易见。
During the 1950s and 60s, as schools in the US began to integrate, black and white kids were increasingly photographed side by side in earbooks. In parents of black kids started noticing the way that their kids didn't look right in those images. But for a long time, Kodak didn't make any changes to the chemistry of their film. When I think about Kodak, I think of Kodak being a company centered in Rochester, New York. I don't think of it as a place that has a lot of black people. That was especially true back in the 1950s.
在 20世纪 50年代和 60年代，随着美国学校开始种族融合，黑人儿童和白人儿童越来越多地并排出现在年鉴中。黑人孩子的父母开始注意到，他们的孩子在这些照片中看起来很不自然。但很长一段时间里，柯达并没有对他们胶卷的化学成分做出任何改变。每当我想起柯达，我就会想起一家总部设在纽约州罗切斯特的公司。我不认为那是一个有很多黑人的地方。早在 20世纪 50年代尤其如此。
And I don't think of Kodak being a employer at high levels of decision making that there are a lot of black people present, so that some of those things may have been avoided because someone's been like, and you know, there's a whole spectrum of shades that we need to make sure you can consider. On top of that, there was this attitude among chemists and researchers at Kodak that photography was just science. They didn't think the film itself could be changed to solve any of these problems, they thought. This is not a matter of choices. We can't change film because that's the way it is.
而且我不认为柯达在高级决策层有很多黑人员工在场，这样一来，其中一些问题可能就可以避免了，因为有人会说，“你知道，我们有各种各样的色调，我们需要确保你把这些考虑进去。”最重要的是，柯达的化学家和研究人员有一种态度，即摄影只是科学。他们认为胶卷本身无法改变来解决这些问题。这不是选择的问题。我们不能改变胶卷，因为事情就是这样的。
This dictates the way it should be. But Kodak, as a company, had proved it could solve big problems when it wanted to. In the 60s, they helped map the entire surface of the moon for the Apollo 11 landing. And around the same time, Kodak actually did start making some changes to their commercial film as well. But not because they were listening to the complaints from people of color. The story would probably be shorter and end better if they had.
这就决定了它该有的样子。但柯达作为一家公司，在想要解决重大问题时已经证明了自己能够做到。在 60年代，他们帮助阿波罗 11 号登月绘制了整个月球表面的地图。大约在同一时期，柯达实际上也开始对他们的商业胶卷做了一些改变。但不是因为他们听取了有色人种的抱怨。如果他们听取了，这个故事可能会更短，结局也更好。
Instead, Kodak changed their film because they were going to lose the business of two big professional clients, a chocolate company and a furniture company. Because dark wood-grained furniture and the lighter version couldn't be differentiated, they all look the same. And milk chocolate, as well as dark chocolate, looked the same. The problem again was the film's dynamic range, the same concept that affects how you photograph skin tones. The chemistry had been very monochromatic in terms of like it would produce a brown, but the brown was the same. It was
相反，柯达改变胶卷是因为他们将失去两个大型专业客户的业务：一家巧克力公司和一家家具公司。因为深色木纹家具和浅色版本无法区分，它们看起来都一样。牛奶巧克力和黑巧克力看起来也一样。问题依然是胶卷的动态范围，这个概念同样影响着你如何拍摄肤色。就产生棕色而言，其化学性质非常单一，它会产生棕色，但这种棕色是相同的。它
like one shade of brown as opposed to like a hundred shades of brown or whatever, you know. According to Earl Cage, the former manager of Kodak Research Studios, the company had never even considered Cage, the former manager of Kodak Research Studios, the company had never even considered how expanding the dynamic range of their film would also improve how dark skin tones are rendered. He noted, quote, it is fascinating that this has never been said before, because it was never black flesh that was addressed as a serious problem that I knew of at the time. Unquote. By the 1980s, Kodak made adjustments to their film emotions and eventually introduced a product called Gold Max. Gold Max was leaps ahead of earlier Kodak films when it came
就像只有一种棕色，而不是像一百种棕色或其他什么，你知道的。据柯达研究工作室前经理厄尔·凯奇称，该公司甚至从未考虑过——凯奇是柯达研究工作室前经理，该公司甚至从未考虑过——扩大胶卷的动态范围将如何同时改善深色肤色的呈现方式。他指出：“引人注目的是，以前从未有人说过这一点，因为据我当时所知，黑人的肤色从未被当作一个严重的问题来处理。”到 20世纪 80年代，柯达对他们的胶卷感光乳剂进行了调整，并最终推出了一种名为“Gold Max”的产品。在色彩表现方面，Gold Max 比早期的柯达胶卷有了飞跃式的进步，公司也是这样宣传它的，但却没有真正承认之前内置在胶卷中的偏见。
to color representation and the company advertised it that way, but without actually acknowledging the bias that had been baked into the film before. It was a consumer film that it claimed could photograph a dark horse in low light, which to me was an encoded way of saying we can use this film to create beautiful images of people with darker skins in low light. As Kodak started becoming more aware of racial bias in color imaging, they also introduced a multi-racial Shirley card. It would have a black person, an Asian person, and a white person. Alongside these changes at Kodak, digital photography started to grow. Home photographers transitioned to digital cameras whose dynamic range turned out to be much
这是一种消费级胶卷，声称可以在弱光下拍摄一匹黑马，对我来说，这是一种委婉的说法，意思是我们可以使用这种胶卷在弱光下为肤色较深的人创作美丽的影像。随着柯达开始更加意识到彩色成像中的种族偏见，他们还推出了多族裔雪莉卡。它会有一个黑人、一个亚裔和一个白人。除了柯达的这些变化，数字摄影开始发展。家庭摄影师过渡到数字相机，其实际动态范围被证明在捕捉更深色调方面要好得多。
better at capturing darker shades. This made photographing a wide range of people easier than it was in the days of film. Digital photography also killed the one-hour photo lab, making the Shirley Cards obsolete. Now home photographers could take and edit photos without the bias built into Kodak's early film and printing processes. But even though the technology of today is way better than the technology of the 1960s and 70s, there is still a lot of cultural inertia preventing dark skin from being photographed in compelling ways.
这使得拍摄形形色色的人比胶卷时代更容易。数字摄影也扼杀了快速冲洗店，使雪莉卡变得过时。现在，家庭摄影师可以拍摄和编辑照片，而没有柯达早期胶卷和冲洗流程中内置的偏见。但尽管当今的技术远比 60 和 70 年代的更好，仍有大量的文化惯性阻碍着以引人注目的方式拍摄深色皮肤。
Photography and cinematography isn't just about the film used or the digital sensor in your camera or the techniques used to process your images. It's also about lighting and staging and all these other elements. In other words, photography is still all about choices and in many ways people still stumble when creating images of darker skin. A common mistake is to overcompensate and make everything too bright. If you look at sitcoms from the 90s, for example, Black Red shows like the Fresh Prince of Bel Air have an overlit, washed out look. That's because the producers are dumping way too much light on the set. Compare that to another show from the era like full house and you'll
摄影和电影摄影不仅仅关于所使用的胶卷、相机中的数字传感器或用于处理影像的技术。它还关于灯光、布景和所有这些其他元素。换句话说，摄影仍然完全关乎选择，在许多方面，人们在创作深色皮肤的影像时仍然会跌跟头。一个常见的错误是矫枉过正，把一切都弄得太亮。例如，如果你看看 90年代的情景喜剧，
see that the approach to lighting dark skin is heavy handed. I think that the super bright look is a result of people just being like, well, I just like we can't see people of color unless it's really bright because they're dark. So we have to add more light.
像《新鲜王子妙事多》这样的黑人情景喜剧，都有着过度打光、泛白的外观。那是因为制片人在布景上倾泻了太多的光线。将其与那个时代的另一部剧如《欢乐满屋》进行比较，你就会发现这种处理深色皮肤光线的方法非常生硬。我认为这种超级明亮的视觉效果是因为人们觉得，嗯，我们根本看不到有色人种，除非光线非常亮，因为他们皮肤黑。所以我们必须增加更多的光线。
This is Ava Brakowski, a cinematographer who has worked on TV shows like insecure. You know, I don't even know what to say to that because it's not very nuanced. It's not very nuanced, but neither was anything Brakowski learned in film school about lighting dark skin. Brakowski says their lighting workshops never used a single person of color as a standard model.
这是阿娃·布拉科夫斯基，一位曾参与过《不安感》等电视剧的电影摄影师。你知道，我甚至不知道该对此说些什么，因为它很不细腻。它很不细腻，但布拉科夫斯基在电影学院学到的关于如何为深色皮肤打光的任何知识也同样不细腻。布拉科夫斯基说，他们的灯光工作坊从来没有把任何一个有色人种当作标准模特。
And when their instructors did talk about lighting people with darker skin tones, it was always talked about like it was a real headache. Like, oh, that's going to be tough. You know, I'm got sick of seeing pretty white girls in front of the camera all the time. And you're like, oh, if you can make this pretty white girl look like a pretty white girl, then you have succeeded and you're a good cinematographer. And it's just not that's not what happens. That's not what's interesting. With Justice Gordon Parks figured out how to work within the limitations of photography,
当他们的讲师谈到如何为肤色较深的人打光时，总是把它说得像是一件让人头疼的大麻烦。比如，哦，那可太难了。你知道的，我厌倦了总是看到漂亮的白人女孩出现在镜头前。然后你会觉得，哦，如果你能把这个漂亮的白人女孩拍得像个漂亮的白人女孩，那你算成功了，你就是个优秀的摄影师。但事实并非如此，那并不是真正有趣的地方。正如戈登·帕克斯弄清楚如何在摄影的局限性中工作一样，
there have been pioneering cinematographers who have done the same in TV and film. There's Ernest Dickerson, for example, who shot a lot of Spike Lee's movies, and now there's a whole new generation of cinematographers who are bringing this kind of dexterity to their work, like Kira Kelly and Bradford Young, who shot Soma. So when Brackowski started working on insecure, they studied the work of Dickerson and others to come up with a visual language that worked for the show. Instead of signing lights directly on the actors, creating the overly bright, washed out,
电视和电影领域也有许多开拓性的电影摄影师做到了这一点。例如欧内斯特·迪克森，他拍摄了斯派克·李的许多电影，现在有一代全新电影摄影师正将这种娴熟技巧带入他们的工作中，比如基拉·凯利和布拉德福德·杨，后者拍摄了《降临》。因此，当布拉科夫斯基开始参与《不安感》的工作时，他们研究了迪克森和其他人的作品，为该剧寻找一种行之有效的视觉语言。布拉科夫斯基没有将灯光直接打在演员身上，从而产生过度明亮、泛白的
fresh, prince of Belair look, Rukovsky used reflective lighting, which bounces light off of white fabric to create a more luminous glow on the actors. And it works. The show is gorgeous. It's full of beautifully lit scenes. Yeah, this is the first time
《新鲜王子妙事多》那种风格，而是使用了反射光，将光线从白色的织物上弹开，在演员身上营造出一种更加柔和的光晕。这很管用。这部剧美极了。它充满了打光精美的场景。是的，这是第一次
that there's nothing in the way of us getting together. So isn't that worth exploring? No. Say, I just got a great course on a beach. Yes. What I would hope is that there's a beauty to the image. And if you shoot people of color, those same way you shoot white people,
没有什么能阻挡我们在一起。难道这不值得探索吗？不。听着，我在海滩上有个绝佳的去处。是的。我希望的是，影像中有一种美。如果你拍摄有色人种时
you're not gonna find that beauty. You're not gonna find that specificity. Today, it's much less the technology we're working against when it comes to accurate representation of images. It's the users of the technology and the institutions around them that shape the images we see. And of course, there are still problems. Every other month, it feels like there's a new dust up on Twitter as people rail against some terrible magazine cover shot by someone who didn't pay enough attention to skin tone. But even if Codex early promise was, you press a button, we do the rest, the technology
采用拍摄白人的那种方式，你是找不到那种美的。你是找不到那种特质的。如今，在追求准确呈现影像方面，阻碍我们的已经不再是技术本身。而是技术的用户以及他们周围塑造我们所见影像的机构。当然，问题依然存在。每隔几个月，推特上就会爆发一场新的争论，人们猛烈抨击那些由不够关注肤色的人所拍摄的糟糕杂志封面。但即使柯达早期的承诺是“你按快门，其余交给我们”，这项技术
will never achieve point-and-click perfection. Because no technology is ever neutral. There will always be choices and trade-offs and aesthetic judgments. The camera is an amazing tool. But the work of creating a beautiful image, on that part, is up to us. Coming up after the break, we talk about another infamous image and the technological legacy of a Swedish model named Elena after this. So we're back with Delaney Hall, hey Delaney. Hey Roman.
也永远无法实现“点击即完美”的境界。因为没有一项技术是真正中立的。永远都会有选择、权衡和审美的判断。相机是一个了不起的工具。但创作一张美丽影像的工作，那部分要靠我们自己。休息片刻后，我们将讨论另一个臭名昭著的影像，以及一个名叫埃琳娜的瑞典模特的科技遗产，广告之后见。我们回来了，德兰妮·霍尔，嗨，德兰妮。嗨，罗曼。
So what do you have for us? So I was the editor on the story we just heard. And as I was working with Kai McNeigh, the reporter on it, I kept thinking about this other story, which I almost pitched our show a few years ago. It turns out it connects to the Shirley Card story in a really uncanny way, and so I wanted to share it with you. Cool, hit me. So the story is about another infamous image that helped create a technology that we use
那么你给我们带来了什么？我是我们刚听到的这个故事的编辑。当我与该故事的记者凯·麦克纳米合作时，我一直在思考另一个故事，几年前我差点向我们节目推介过它。事实不可思议地与雪莉卡的故事联系在一起，所以我很想跟你分享。酷，说来听听。这个故事关于另一个臭名昭著的影像，它帮助催生了我们
pretty much every day. And that technology is the JPEG. It's a format for compressing image files. And so, yeah, so practically every photo you've ever taken, every website you've ever visited owes some debt to this image, which is of a Swedish woman named Lena Forsen. Okay. So Lena Forsen. Okay, so Lena Forsen has like the Shirley Page of computer images.
几乎每天都在使用的一项技术。这项技术就是 JPEG。它是一种用于压缩影像文件的格式。所以，是的，实际上你拍过的每一张照片、访问过的每一个网站，都亏欠了这个影像，照片上是一位名叫莉娜·福森的瑞典女性。好的。所以，莉娜·福森。好的，所以莉娜·福森就像是计算机影像中的雪莉·佩奇。
Yeah, yeah, she is the Shirley Page analog in this story. And the first thing I should say is that there have been a number of great stories about Lena and her role in tech history. Notably there was one in Wired by a writer named Linda Kinsler, who actually interviewed Lena and learned about her life story. And the way it goes is that back in 1972, when Lena was 21, she appeared as misnovember in Playboy magazine. It was a nude photo. She was wearing a feathered hat and boots and stockings and a pink boa. Kind of a classic 1972 centerfold image. Yes, exactly. It is very
是的，是的，她就是这个故事里的雪莉·佩奇的类似存在。我首先要说的是，关于莉娜以及她在科技史上的角色，有很多精彩的故事。特别是《连线》杂志上有一篇由作家琳达·金斯勒撰写的文章，她实际上采访了莉娜并了解了她的人生故事。事情是这样的，早在 1972年，莉娜 21岁时，她作为《花花公子》杂志的“11月玩伴”亮相。那是一张裸照。她戴着一顶羽毛帽、穿着靴子、丝袜和粉红色羽毛围巾。有点像 1972 年经典的中心折页影像。是的，完全如此。这非常
70s. So a few months after that image was published, a copy of it showed up at the University of Southern California's Signal and Image Processing Institute, which was doing pioneering work at the time in the field of image processing. There was this team of researchers there, and they were developing an algorithm that could make big image files smaller and more manageable, easier to share. And as it turns out, they were looking for a new photograph to use in their tests of this new compression algorithm. And they decided that Lena's centerfold picture would be a good candidate.
70年代。所以在那张影像发表几个月后，它的副本出现在南加州大学信号与图像处理研究所，该研究所在当时的图像处理领域做出了开创性的工作。当时那里有一支研究人员团队，他们正在开发一种算法，可以使大型影像文件变得更小、更易于管理、更易于分享。事实证明，他们正在寻找一张新照片来测试这个新的压缩算法。他们决定莉娜的中心折页照片会是一个很好的候选对象。
I bet they did. I mean, other than the fact that, you know, these dudes wanted a picture of a naked woman to work with all the time. Was there any sort of rationale as to why this image over anything else? I mean, there were some technical arguments and favor of it, you know, it was an image that featured a complex range of colors and textures. It had a human face. It had the texture of feathers.
我敢说他们确实这么想。我的意思是，除了这些家伙想要一张裸女的照片来一直处理之外，有什么关于为什么选这张影像而不是其他任何东西的理由吗？我的意思是，有一些有利于它的技术论据，你知道的，这是一个具有复杂的颜色和纹理范围的影像。它有人脸。它有羽毛的质感。
Like there were things that made it a good test image. I see, I see. But you could imagine picking a picture with a complex range of colors and textures or someone else with a boa around their neck and not using image from Playboy. Yes, yes. You could have found any number of other pictures that were not a naked woman,
有一些因素使它成为一个很好的测试影像。我明白了，我明白了。但你可以想象选择一张具有复杂的颜色和纹理范围的图片，或者脖子上缠着羽毛围巾的其他人，而不一定要使用来自《花花公子》的影像。是的，是的。你可以找到许多其他不是裸女的照片，
but that is not what happened. What they did is they tore off the bottom of the image and then they converted Lena's top half kind of from her shoulders up into a digital image, which they then used in their compression testing. Soon, that image of Lena, looking over her bare shoulder, became an industry standard. It was replicated millions of times as the format that we now know of as the JPEG came into being. Oh, and so, I mean, you stated that it had a lot of, you know, textures and colors and stuff, but is there just a reason this line of image got used over and over again besides
但事实并非如此。他们做的是撕掉了影像的底部，然后把莉娜的上半身（从肩膀往上）转换成数字影像，接着在压缩测试中使用了这个影像。很快，莉娜越过赤裸肩膀回眸的影像，成为了行业标准。它被复制了数百万次，随着我们现在所知的 JPEG 格式的诞生。哦，所以，我的意思是，你提到它有很多，你知道的，纹理和颜色之类的东西，但除了
just kind of habit? Well, yeah, I mean, it's hard to imagine now, but back then in the 1970s, scanners were rare. Digitized images were hard to come by. And so the library of images at USC quickly became the standard for imaging scientists around the country. And Lena was one of the main images in that library. There was an image of colorful bell peppers
习惯之外，这张特定影像被一遍又一遍地使用的原因仅仅是习惯吗？嗯，是的，我的意思是，现在很难想象，但在当时的 70 年代，扫描仪非常罕见。数字化影像很难获得。因此，南加州大学的影像库迅速成为全国影像科学家的标准。莉娜是该影像库中的主要影像之一。有一张彩色甜椒的影像
that got used a lot too, and like a mandrel's face, but Lena was one of the main ones. And then beyond that, the researchers who build and test algorithms actually like to use images that have been used before, because then you can immediately make comparisons to previous iterations of your algorithm or to other algorithms that are out there.
也被用了很多次，还有山魈的脸，但莉娜是主要的影像之一。除此之外，构建和测试算法的研究人员实际上喜欢使用以前用过的影像，因为这样你可以立即与你的算法的先前迭代或其他现有的算法进行比较。
Right, you keep the image the same, so you can create a standard to compare different algorithms against that does make sense. Right. Right. And so because of that, because of those factors, the Lena image became one of the most common images in the field. She was one of the first pictures uploaded to Arpanet, which was the precursor to the internet. She's in thousands of papers. You'll still see her image at conferences today, and she just became iconic. Like some computer scientist just call her the Lena. She just ubiquitous. She can, she's a chair. You can refer to her by her first name, and that's just, you know exactly who you're talking about. Yeah, I mean, but at some point or at any point, was there pushback of this standard image being
没错，你保持影像不变，这样你就可以创建一个标准来将不同的算法进行对比，这确实说得通。没错。没错。正因如此，由于这些因素，莉娜的影像成为了该领域最常见的影像之一。她是上传到阿帕网（互联网的前身）最早的照片之一。她出现在数千篇论文中。你今天在会议上仍然会看到她的影像，她简直成了标志性的存在。就像一些计算机科学家直接管她叫“莉娜”。她无处不在。你可以用她的名字来称呼她，你知道你谈论的正是她。是的，我的意思是，但是在某个时刻或任何时刻，对于这个标准影像竟然是
a center of fault from Playboy? Yes, absolutely. So over the years, women in the field of computer science, you know, who are still vastly outnumbered by men have talked about how alienating it is to see Lena, for example, projected up on the screen during lectures in college or high school. They've described their mostly male classmates laughing or awgling her, and that's weird for them, as you can imagine.
来自《花花公子的中心折页》这件事情，有过反对意见吗？是的，绝对有。多年来，计算机科学领域的女性（她们的人数仍然远远少于男性）一直在谈论，在大学或高中的讲座中看到莉娜被投影到屏幕上是多么令人感到疏离。她们形容她们的大多数男同学会发出笑声或对她挤眉弄眼，你可以想象，这让她们感觉很怪异。
Yeah, I can't. I mean, it would make me kind of uncomfortable in a classroom to tell you can imagine. Yeah, I can't. I mean, it would make me kind of uncomfortable in a classroom to tell you the truth. And people have pushed back, they have tried to change this. So in particular, there have been some women professors who have protested. There was a math professor at UCLA who, along with a colleague, acquired rights to a headshot of Fabio. And they used that in their imaging research instead of Lena. That ties back to another story we did about romance covers.
是的，我能想象。我的意思是，说实话，在课堂上这会让我觉得有点不舒服。人们进行了反抗，他们曾试图改变这一点。特别是一些女性教授曾进行过抗议。加州大学洛杉矶分校的一位数学教授曾和一位同事一起购买了法比奥大头照的版权。他们在影像研究中用这个代替了莉娜。这与我们做过的关于浪漫小说封面的另一个故事有关。
But I mean, so you mentioned that a reporter from wire had talked to Lena. I mean, she posed for Playboy, but didn't know this image would be, like co-opted for computer science and JPEG algorithms. I mean, what, you know, how were she of all this and what happened to her? So after her centerfold photo was published, Lena did not do any more pictures for Playboy. She was living in the U.S. at the time.
但我的意思是，你提到《连线》的一位记者曾与莉娜交谈过。我的意思是，她为《花花公子》拍过照，但并不知道这个影像会被用于计算机科学和 JPEG 算法中。我的意思是，她对此怎么看，她后来怎么样了？在她的中心折页照片发表后，莉娜没有再为《花花公子》拍过照。她当时住在美国。
This is still back in the 1970s. And she got divorced from her then husband. She got a new boyfriend. And together they move to Rochester, New York, which you might remember from the story we just heard is the headquarters of Kodak. That's an interesting connection. Yeah, okay, but the connection is deeper than that, because while in Rochester, Lena got a job working as a Kodak model, and she became one of the companies Shirley's. That's crazy. Isn't it? I could not believe it when I first read about it because working on the Shirley Card
这依然是在 20世纪 70年代。她和当时丈夫离婚了。她交了个新男朋友。他们一起搬到了纽约州罗切斯特市，你可能从我们刚听到的故事中记得，那是柯达的总部。这是一个有趣的联系。是的，好吧，这种联系更深，因为在罗切斯特期间，莉娜找到了一份工作，担任柯达的模特，并成为了该公司的雪莉之一。这太疯狂了。不是吗？我第一次读到它时简直不敢相信，因为从事雪莉卡
story got me thinking about Lena and I like went back and started reading about her again. And then there's this chapter in her history that just connects exactly to the Shirley card story. She was on those color testing cards that Kodak sent out to printing labs across the country. Oh, that's amazing. So not only was she the digital standard to calibrate things, she became one of the original analog standards to calibrate images too. That's a, what an amazing coincidence. Isn't that wild? Yeah, I love it. And so this whole time when she was in Rochester and computer sciences developing, was she aware of that the whole time that her image was being used in this way for computer imagery or was this something that came like way later? Yeah, I am not sure exactly when she became aware, but I know that over time she has become aware. So she has attended technical conferences, in fact, that wired article I
的故事让我想起了莉娜，我又回去开始重新阅读关于她的资料。然后她的历史中刚好有这样一个章节，与雪莉卡的故事完全契合。她出现在柯达寄给全国各地印刷实验室的那些色彩测试卡上。哦，太神奇了。所以她不仅是校准事物的数字标准，她还成了校准影像的原始模拟标准之一。这真是一个令人惊叹的巧合。不是很疯狂吗？是的，我喜欢它。所以在她在罗切斯特以及计算机科学发展的整个过程中，她一直都知道她的影像被以这种方式用于计算机影像，还是这是很久以后才发生的事情？是的，我不确定她是什么时候知道的，但我知道随着时间的推移，她已经知道了。因此，事实上，她参加过技术会议，我提到的那篇《连线》文章
mentioned described a scene from 2015 when Lena was a special guest at an image processing industry conference in Quebec. And there were photos of the event that show her like stepping on stage through a shimmering projection of her iconic photo. Yeah. Okay. Well, I'm glad that she's like that she owns it in a fun way. If that's what she's into it, yeah, that's great.
描述了 2015 年的一个场景，当时莉娜是魁北克一个图像处理行业会议的特邀嘉宾。活动的照片显示，她从她标志性照片的光影投影中走上舞台。好吧。嗯，我很高兴她能以一种有趣的方式坦然接受。如果那是她所享受的，是的，那就太棒了。
Yeah, and you know, the author of that wired article, Linda Kinsler, managed to track Lena down a few years back because while it was clear that Lena knew of the image and had sort of attended some conferences, there wasn't a lot of information about how she felt about it. And so in that article, Lena actually expressed a alarm at the thought that she could be playing a part in herding or discouraging young women, so much so that she actually participated in a recent documentary that came out a couple years ago called Luzine Lena. And that film documents the history of the Lena image,
是的，你知道，《连线》的那位作者琳达·金斯勒几年前设法找到了莉娜，因为虽然很明显莉娜知道这个影像，并且参加过一些会议，但并没有太多关于她对此有何感受的信息。因此在那篇文章中，莉娜实际上对她可能在伤害或打击年轻女性方面扮演了角色表达了震惊，以至于她实际上参与了近年来推出的一部名为《寻找莉娜》的纪录片。这部纪录片记录了莉娜影像的历史，
and then it also calls on researchers to abandon the image and find something new. I'm Lena. I retired from modeling a long time ago. It's time I retired from take two. tired from take two. I imagine other than the sort of sexism inherent in the image that coming up with something new would also be who've, you know, just computer imagery in general just because, you know, a single picture of a white woman, you know, it's just this problematic in terms of creating a kind of narrow standard as it is on the Shirley card.
然后它也呼吁研究人员放弃这个影像并寻找新的东西。我是莉娜。我很久以前就从模特界退休了。是时候我从“第二次机会”退休了。我猜，除了影像中固有的性别歧视之外，想出一些新东西对总体计算机影像来说也是一件好事，因为正如雪莉卡那样，单一白人女性的照片在建立一种狭隘标准方面同样存在问题。
Right. Exactly. You could imagine a test image with a more diverse array of people on it where you really get a sense that the algorithm is working well across skin tones, for example, in the way that the Shirley Card didn't do at least originally. So yeah, I think there's various arguments for changing the standard in this field. Wow. Well, it's super fascinating, and I can't believe there's actually a Shirley Card connection that she became the digital standard for digital images and analog images as well. That's just stunning to me. It's such an interesting collision of stories. Yeah, well, thank you so much.
没错。完全正确。你可以想象一个测试影像，上面有更多元化的人群，在那里你真的能感受到该算法在不同的肤色下运行良好，例如雪莉卡（至少最初）没有做到的那样。所以，是的，我认为这个领域有各种各样的理由来改变标准。哇。这真的超级吸引人，我无法相信居然有一个雪莉卡的联系，她成为了数字影像和模拟影像的数字标准。这对我来说太震撼了。这真是一次有趣的故事碰撞。是的，非常感谢。
It was a great coat. I love it. Okay, thanks, Roman. And we'll include links to that wired article and the Luzin Lennah documentary on our website in case people want to learn more. And that website is 99pi.org. 99% of what was produced this week by Kai McNamey, edited by our Executive Producer,
这是一件很棒的外套。我很喜欢。好的，谢谢，罗曼。我们将在我们的网站上提供《连线》文章和《寻找莉娜》纪录片的链接，以防人们想了解更多。该网站是 99pi.org。本周 99% 的内容由凯·麦克纳米制作，由我们的执行制片人
Delaney Hall, mixed in tech production by Amida Ganatra, fact checking by Francis Card Jr. Music by our director of Sound, Swan Rial. Kurt Colftid is the digital director, special thanks this week to the LA Center of Photography, Tom Allerman and Serita McFadden. The rest of 99 PI team includes Vivian Le, Boshamadon, Christopher Johnson, and Fitzgerald, Chris Baroube, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are part of the Stitcher & Serious XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north
德兰妮·霍尔编辑，音频制作由阿米达·加纳特拉混音，事实核查由小弗朗西斯·卡德负责。音乐由我们的声音总监斯旺·里阿尔创作。库尔特·科尔夫蒂德是数字总监，本周特别感谢洛杉矶摄影中心、汤姆·阿勒曼和塞丽塔·麦克法登。99 PI 团队的其他成员包括莉·维维安、博沙·马顿、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、安德烈·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯·巴鲁贝、乔·罗森伯格、索菲亚·克拉茨克以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是 Stitcher & Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于北边六个街区
in the Pandora building, and beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. On Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI dot org. .org. Person, woman, man, camera, TV, stichre, Sirius XM. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市 uptown 美丽的潘多拉大厦。您可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与讨论。您可以在 Twitter 上 @Roman Mars 或本节目 @99PI org。Instagram 和 Reddit 上也可以。您可以在 99PI dot org 上找到我喜爱的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及 99PI 的所有往期节目。.org。人，女人，男人，相机，电视，stichre，Sirius XM。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。